FAR WITH JUAN WILLIAMS,
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
TONIGHT, NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
SHOWDOWN OVER A CLASSIFIED MEMO
ON A LARGE SURVEILLANCE ABUSES
BY THE FBI AND THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS EXPECTED TO
APPROVE THE RELEASE OF THE
DOCUMENTS AFTER AGREEING TO SOME
READ ACTIONS AT THE FBI'S
REQUEST.
IT COULD BE DECLASSIFIED
POSSIBLY BY TOMORROW MORNING.
THIS AFTERNOON, SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN ADVOCATED FOR ITS
RELEASE AS LONG AS SOURCES AND
METHODS ARE REVEALED.
>> LET ME TELL WHAT THIS IS AND
WHAT IT'S NOT.
IT IS CONGRESS DOING ITS JOB AND
CONDUCTING LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT
OVER A UNIQUE LAW, FAISAL.
IF MISTAKES WERE MADE AND IF
INDIVIDUALS DID SOMETHING WRONG,
THEN IT'S OUR JOB AS LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT OVER
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
WITH THIS IS NOT IS AN
INDICTMENT ON OUR INSTITUTIONS,
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT AN INDICTMENT OF THE
THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN GIVEN
EXTRA IN HER POWER OVER
CITIZENS' CIVIL LIBERTIES.
THE PROCESS IS FOLLOWED PROPERL
PROPERLY.
>> Kimberly: THE MEMO WAS
COMMISSIONED BY DEVIN NUNES,
REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE PANEL.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS PELOSI AND
SHARON CALLED FOR NUNES' REMOVAL
SHARON CALLED FOR NUNES' REMOVA
SPEAKER THEIR PLAYING POLITICS
LOOKING FOR A DISTRACTION.
DEVIN NUNES HELP SHEPHERD
SURVEILLANCE LAW.
FOCUSED ON KEEPING THE COUNTRY
SAFE AND NATIONAL SECURITY.
I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO
SIDETRACK US.
>> Kimberly: WE ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO GET SOME BREAKING NEWS
ON THIS TOMORROW THAT'S GOING TO
BE RELEASED IN TERMS OF
REPORTING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN EXPECT
AND WHAT TO THINK ABOUT THE
MESSAGING?
>> Dana: I'M NOT SURE.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT SPEAKER RYAN
IS TRYING TO DO.
A COUPLE THINGS COME HE'S TRYING
TO EXPLAIN THAT THE MEMO HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE BOB
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
I REALLY THINK THAT'S A VERY
EVEN IF, EVEN IF IT'S TRUE THAT
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT,
EVERYBODY ASSUMES IT HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT.
ALL THESE BACKGROUND SOURCES SAY
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE OR SOME IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, SOMETIMES THEY
SAY THE PRESIDENT, BELIEVES THIS
IS GOING TO HELP HIM IN THE
COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION THINKING
THERE IS BIAS AGAINST HIM AND
THEREFORE QUESTIONS OF
CREDIBILITY OF THE WHOLE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THEN YOU HAVE THE FISA ISSUE,
THERE'S LOTS OF DIFFERENT TITLES
IN THE FISA BILL.
TERRORIST CALLING INTO AMERICANS
AND YOU GET A WARRANTLESS
WIRETAPS, THAT'S ONE PART OF THE
FISA PROGRAM.
WHEN I UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE
DIFFERENT TITLE, TITLE I, WHICH
IS ABOUT BASICALLY GOING AFTER A
WARRANT FOR AN AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHERE THE ABUSES
APPARENTLY WEREN'T REALLY
VALUABLE TO CLARIFY IT.
BEFORE HE CAME TO AIR, REPORTING
ON BACKGROUND SOURCES ON AXIOS
THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE FEARFUL
IT'S NOT ALL IT'S CRACKED UP TO
BE AND MAYBE IT'S BEEN
OVERHYPED.
WHEN SPEAKER RYAN SAYS PELOSI
AND SCHUMER ARE CALLING FOR
DISTRACTION BY SAYING NUNES
SHOULD STEP DOWN, YOU DO HAVE TO
THINK THAT THE REPUBLICANS OF
ACTUALLY BEEN LOOKING FOR A
DISTRACTION FOR THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS AS THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH
PROPER CHANNELS OR TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO RELEASE THE MEMO.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF IT?
OVERHYPING?
NERVOUS ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN HYPING THIS BIGGER THAN
I'VE EVER SEEN.
IS GOING TO BE VERY
DISAPPOINTED.
WITH THAT SAID, THE WAY PELOSI
IS ACTING IN THE WAY ERIC HOLDER
IS ACTING, AND THE WAY JAMES
COMEY'S ACT ACTIVE, HE LEADS ME
TO BELIEVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS AT
LEAST THINK IT'S A VERY DAMNING
MEMO THAT'S GOING TO HURT THE
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT PAUL RYAN
SAYS IT'S NOT.
THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT
REPUBLICANS' COMMUNICATIONS
MESSAGING IS HARD.
THEY ARE SAYING IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE RUSSIA
REASONABLY SO.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE
CONFLATION COMES IN TERMS OF ONE
THAT THIS DOSSIER THAT WAS PAID
FOR BY HILLARY AND WAS FAKE WAS
USED AS THE JUSTIFICATION IS BY
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT SEEMS LIKE THE HARDEST BIT
OF EVIDENCE WE HAVE.
AS FAR AS ANYTHING ELSE, IT
LOOKS LIKE COMEY HAS BEEN
IMPLICATED IN SOME CAPACITY.
ROSENSTEIN HAS BEEN IMPLICATED.
EVERY THOSE NAMES BANDIED ABOUT.
NOW THEY WANT TO REDACT THOSE
NAMES.
I DON'T SEE WHAT REDACTING NAMES
WILL DO.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY HAVE
CHANGED THE MEMO.
CHANGE.
THE OTHER CHANGE WAS SOMETHING
THE DEMOCRATS WANTED.
THE SMOKE SCREEN, THE DEMOCRATS
LIKE TO SAY, IT'S A SMOKE SCREEN
FOR THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW DEPLOYING
A SMOKE SCREEN FOR THE ABUSE OF
POWER BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT DOES
LOOK LIKE, PEOPLE WERE DEBATING
WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT KNOWING TOO MUCH AND
ABUSING THEIR POWER FROM GETTING
INTO PERSONAL STUFF.
LOOKS LIKE SOME OF THOSE FEARS
WERE FOUNDED ON, YOU KNOW,
JUST RELEASE THE DAMN THING.
>> Kimberly: TOMORROW IT WILL
BE OVER FOR YOU.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
PAUL RYAN MAKING THE STATEMENT.
SOME PEOPLE WANT THIS TO COME
OUT TODAY, AND OF TIME, VERSUS
FRIDAY.
>> Greg: YEAH, I LOVE OUR
VIEWERS.
I LOVE OUR VIEWERS SO MUCH THAT
I SOMETIMES HAVE TO GIVE THEM
SOME TOUGH TALK.
THIS IS A MEMO INTERVENTION.
THE MORE THIS IS PLAYED UP ON
CABLE NEWS, THE LESS IT MAY BE.
YOU'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN WITH
OTHER SCANDALS.
I CALL IT LIFE DOWN -ITIS.
IT FIZZLES AND WE MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
IT IS LIKE THE REBOOT OF "FULL
HOUSE."
I WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO IT WAS
A BIG LETDOWN.
WITH THE RUSSIAN INCLUSION
THING, IT'S THE SAME THING.
YOU LOOK AT THE MEMO.
IT IS LIKE COMPETITIVE STRIP
TEASE.
ONE SIDE IS SAYING LOOK AT THIS,
LOOK AT THIS.
THE OTHER SITE'S LOOK AT THIS,
YOU LOOK AT THAT ANY LOOK AT
THAT, HE REALIZED THIS IS THE
WORST STRIP CLUB EVER.
MSNBC, RACHEL IS FANTASTIC AND
EVERY DAY SHE IS TELLING THE
AND AT OTHER NETWORKS, IT IS THE
MEMO TELLING THAT STORY.
IT IS SCANDAL PING-PONG.
>> Jesse: COMPETITIVE STRIP
TEASE COMING TO A THEATER NEAR
YOU.
>> Kimberly: SCANDAL PONG.
>> Greg: I COULD BE WRONG.
I'VE BEEN WRONG BEFORE.
I HATE TALKING ABOUT STUFF I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT BUT IF I FOLLOW
THAT, I WOULD NEVER OPEN MY
MOUTH.
SO I AM GOING TO SAY A
PREDICTION THAT WE PROBABLY WILL
BE LET DOWN.
IF I'M WRONG, THEN WE'LL TALK
ABOUT IT TOMORROW.
WE'LL PROBABLY LEAD WITH IT.
>> Kimberly: WHAT A HAPPY
FRIDAY IT WILL BE.
JUAN, DO YOU THINK IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE REPUBLICANS, SOME OF
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> Juan: I THINK THE PURPOSE
IS PRETTY APPARENT, WHICH IS
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DOESN'T
LIKE THE INVESTIGATION.
HE IS TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
FBI, JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AS PART
OF AN EFFORT TO GET HIS
SUPPORTERS TO DISBELIEVE
ANYTHING THAT COMES FROM THE
WHAT IS STRIKING TO ME ABOUT
THIS IS YOU HAD THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI, CHRISTOPHER WRAY, GO
OVER TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO MEET
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF, JOHN KELLY, A COMPANY --
BOTH SAID IT WOULD BE A RECKLESS
ACT, IT WOULD ENDANGER NATIONAL
SECURITY THAT OUT THERE.
THIS WAS A CHERRY PICKED
DOCUMENTS.
THERE ARE OMISSIONS OF FACT THE
THINGS THAT ARE DISTORTED.
AND IT WILL LEAD TO METHODS AND
SOURCES BEING VOLTS.
THEY ASKED.
THESE ARE TWO TRUMP APPOINTEES.
NOT THE DEMOCRATS, WHICH I GUESS
WE CAN, PICKING UP WHAT GREG IS
SAYING, TEAM SPORT POLITICS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR
AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS AND TRUST
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HERE, DESPITE WHAT PAUL RYAN
SAYS, WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
PUTTING HIS INTERESTS, HIS
DISINCLINATION TO LISTEN AND
ABIDE BY ANYTHING THAT'S COMING
FROM THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
OVER THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I AM SURPRISED THE REPUBLICANS,
OVER THE BEST INTEREST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: FOR SO LONG WE'VE
BEEN TOLD HOW HEROIC
WHISTLE-BLOWERS ARE FOR EXPOSING
THIS INFORMATION.
WHERE IS THE CHELSEA MANNING FAN
CLUB RIGHT NOW?
WHY AREN'T THEY SAYING "RELEASE
THE MEMO."
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY REASON
FOR SECRECY AND THE METAL IS I
THINK WHAT'S IN IT, WE ALREADY
KNOW.
I THINK THE IDEA THAT IT'S
TOP-SECRET IS UNFAIR TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE THING.
THE SAME GROUP IT DOES LET'S BE
TRANSPARENT SINCE NO, DEMOCRATS,
YOUR ♪
♪ CAN'T GO OUT.
AND THEN SECONDLY WHEN I ASKED
ABOUT THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
NO, WE CAN'T PUT THAT OUT.
BUT USERS HAVE TO LISTEN TO OUR
INTERPRETATION.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THAT
PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO UNDERMINE
ANYTHING.
I THINK THE CONGRESS IS DOING
OVERSIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT THEIR
JOB IS.
YOU ALSO SAID THE FBI DOESN'T
WANT TO THAT.
OF COURSE THEY DON'T BECAUSE
IT'S VERY EMBARRASSING TO THE
FBI.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, JUAN WILLIAMS
TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NEEDS TO BE -- HAVE BODY CAMERAS
ON THEM AND WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT
FOR BIAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE EVIDENCE OF
BIAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND YOU
WHEN HAS BEEN MADE YET NOT
WANTED MORE INFORMATION.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT USA JOURNALISTS
WANT MORE.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
YOU ARE ON SUCH WEAK GROUND.
I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WANT TO DO
SOME SORT OF PERSONAL ATTACK ON
ME.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT PERSONAL.
>> Juan: YOU TALK ABOUT POLICE
IN THE STREETS IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES, I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE FBI LOOKING AT OUR
POLITICIANS.
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT DOESN'T LIKE
BLACK PEOPLE, WOULDN'T YOU
SUSPECT THAT BLACK COP?
IF THERE IS A BIASED FBI AGENT
THAT DOESN'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP
AND HE IS OVERSEEING THE
INVESTIGATION, WOULDN'T YOU --
>> Juan: MAYBE YOU SHOULD GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE NEWSPAPERS
THAT INDICATE -- YESTERDAY THE
AGENT TO USE THAT DOESN'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP HIM IT WAS
HILLARY CLINTON.
LET'S REOPEN THIS TEN DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Jesse: WHAT ELSE HAPPENS,
McCABE, WAS JUST LET GO TO
COLLECT HIS PENSION, KNEW ABOUT
THESE EXTRA EMAILS THAT HILLARY
HAD AND DIDN'T TELL JAMES COMEY
FOR WEEKS.
WHY NOT?
WHAT WAS HE HIDING?
>> Juan: HE WASN'T HIDING
ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: WHY DID HE WAIT
WEEKS?
>> Juan: COMEY HAS SAID
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Greg: THE GREAT THING ABOUT
THIS IS WE ARE ALL ARGUING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT NOBODY HAS READ
OUTSIDE OF A FEW PEOPLE.
>> Kimberly: BUT WE WILL KNOW.
ONE OTHER POINT,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" JUST
POSTED AN ARTICLE ABOUT CARTER
PAGE IN THE ORIGINAL FISA
WARRANT WHICH IT SAID WAS NOT
DURING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT GOES BACK TO 2013.
THERE IS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" GOT
IT, BUT IF THIS MEMO COMES OUT
TOMORROW AND THE DEMOCRATS WANT
THEIR MEMO RELEASED AS WELL, YOU
CAN BET THAT THERE ARE PROBABLY
OTHER INFORMATION THAT SOMEHOW
LEAKS OUT TRIES TO AT LEAST GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
MAYBE WE WILL ALL KNOW MORE
TOMORROW AFTER THAT MEMO COMES
OUT.
WITH "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
ARTICLE THAT JUST POSTED.
>> Juan: BEFORE WE GO, WHAT
ROSENSTEIN, YOU ARE IMPLICATED
IN THE MEMO.
I WANT YOU GONE AND I'M RIGHT
ABOUT CEMENTING THEIR LIFE AND
THIS IS HORRIBLE?
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
THE COUNTRY IN THIS MANNER TO
PROTECT HIMSELF.
>> Greg: YOU ARE PROPOSING A
QUESTION ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED.